bound forever to quote the bard
for he today that sheds his blood with
me shall be my brother
she today
my sister hey everybody I hope you got
your [ __ ] pants on probably the most
cringe way to close down an episode but
it's negan so you sort of take a
tongue-in-cheek and I'll try to explain
what that cryptic line from Rick was at
the end of the episode my mercy prevails
over my wrath it sort of gave you an
idea for what the overall tone of season
eight is going to be given the subject
matter in the stuff that they're dealing
with in the all-out war storyline
so we'll be doing Walking Dead videos
all season long be sure to subscribe to
get everything there's a new round of
that Amazon giveaway too and that'll
continue every single week I honestly
think that they've corrected a lot of
the mistakes that they made last season
in making that negan storyline so grim
dark and just punishing the audience
without depressing things got so let's
just do top 10 WTF and I'll do comic
book Easter eggs as we go along because
there were a lot of comic book Easter
eggs for all-out war which starts with
volume 20 but that's issue 115 I think
in negan debuted in issue number 100
this is the 100th episode so you figured
they were gonna do something extra
special
but number 10 you have the safe zone
hilltop in the kingdom who have all band
together the Savior's now have that
alliance with Jadis and the scavengers
so those are the two factions right now
they're gonna be a couple new groups
during the season that we'll find out
about later but for the most part they
open up with that big call to action for
Rick trying to set the tone for the
season about how everything is really
hopeful even though what they're about
to do is so crazy they're getting ready
to start a prolonged war he references
the conversation he had with Jesus way
back when he woke him up in bed with
Michonne they were naked in bed Jesus
walks in and says you're part of a
bigger world Rick so if you couldn't
tell they actually jumped around in time
during the episode so you kept cutting
back to this moment here when they're
giving their speech you get speeches
from Ezekiel I love how Sheva just
growled and acceptance Maggie gives her
speech - we had to talk about her -
because Rick gave a big hat tip for what
might be happening after they're done
with all-out war - so all of these
speech scenes were taking place before
the events of most of the episode where
they turned the super heard on the
Savior's but number 9 you have the
choral scene which is actually a mirror
for the very first Rick scene after he
left the hospital
in the pilot episode so he's driving
down the highway it's literally
shot-for-shot the exact same scene but
then Rick comes in and sort of takes you
out of that moment he's not nearly as
trusting as he used to be if you
remember the original scene was as he
came upon that little girl Walker and he
was so ready to try and help her it was
so sad but they do a good job of
juxtaposing what he's like now given all
the stuff that he's been through and how
it seems like he's not very hopeful but
that all kind of goes into that final
line that he has my mercy not my wrath
so I'll explain that because that's a
really important idea for this season
but then later Karl comes back and
leaves some food for the person just as
a way to show you that the characters
are dealing with this terrible situation
in really good ways like they want you
to be very hopeful even though people
are dying left and right which i think
is the big 180 pivot from last season
when people were saying this is just
punishing darkness it's getting so
depressing each week watching the way
negan treats people so that's why
everyone in the episode was so self
assured maggie rick they know exactly
what they need to do they're totally
committed to it and they're even smiling
and hopeful about Maggie's baby that's
going to be born relatively soon but
number eight the list so if you don't
watch the show arrow way back during
season one Oliver Queen the green arrow
had a list of people that he was going
around killing in the city really
terrible people
so that just reminded me of that they
had their own version of the kill list
going around picking all the saviors off
Rick feeding that guy to the zombie was
straight-up cold but I think that's why
they had that tag at the end where he
said that line from the Prophet Mohammed
my mercy prevails not my wrath so they
want to let you know that he's not a
psychopath even though he seems like a
straight-up cold-blooded killer after
moments like this but number seven they
roll up they have a standoff with negan
they fire a couple shots to get him out
and they just start going back and forth
with their big pissing contest
I love the way negan throws the line at
him you don't have the numbers for this
you think you do but the thing is is
that he doesn't know about the super
herd so they literally have nothing but
numbers so that's the big twist I don't
think it paid off quite as big as they
meant it to in the episode because of
the way they cut those final scenes but
you do get that big final shot of them's
urging the sanctuary but really number
six I think the bigger moment here
though is we stand
with Maggie not with Gregory like they
bring him out like negan thinks he has a
one-up on him I'm gonna take hilltop
away from you Rick but I think that all
of us knew where this was headed last
season they telegraphed it pretty
clearly in at no point during this
moment here did I ever think that
anybody was gonna leave this group the
minor change they made from the comic
book because the events of the episode
played out relatively closely to the
comic book was that there were actually
about eight people that left and took
off because they don't want to get
killed
negan still wound up being super pista
craigory but in the episode it was Simon
that retaliated against them and he just
pushed him down the staircase I almost
thought that he was gonna be dead but
then we found out why they left him
alive for that big twist with Gabriel
the only real reminder here though is
that Eugene is still team negan and Josh
McDermitt the actor said that he's
hundred-percent team negan it's not like
he's pretending to be on their side and
he's gonna switch back right away it's
that weird thing where Eugene believes
that that's the best way to survive is
with negan but number five pleasure
doing business with you Daryl brings the
hurt in just like they did I think it
was at the beginning of season five it
seems so long ago where he was leading
the super herd with his bike loved how
he waited for that Walker to pass into
his shop before he set off that final
bomb the execution of the traps worked
pretty well the distractions really of
em shooting the windows out was them
trying to take away that advantage but
also trying to keep them busy so the
Daryl had enough time to get the super
herd up there so that's why they waited
to use the van to blow up the barricade
they didn't want to blow their wad too
soon but number four Gregory that little
[ __ ] steals father Gabriel's car leaving
him stranded the reason why I think they
did this is is because they wanted to do
the Holly twist where somebody gets left
behind and that's going to be Gabriel
like we get negan's [ __ ] pants line
which he actually said to Dwight in the
comic book too so just a couple minor
changes but the reason why Holly got
left behind is is because somebody
needed to ram the barricade to get the
super herd in and she wanted to be that
person but in this instance father
Gabriel who used to be pretty despicable
winds up getting left behind because he
was trying to do something good so you
can see how a lot of the characters
decisions in the episodes let you know
what kind of arc they're on and
ultimately I think that the characters
they want you to hate like
Gregory will meet two spectacularly
grisly deaths like they're not gonna
kill somebody like Gregory off screen
they're gonna let you savor that and
enjoy it because he certainly deserves
something really really awful but the
other thing that they sort of leave for
a future episode to explain is the pay's
industrial research facility we don't
know exactly why they need it but it's a
strategic location and they sort of cut
the episode before we found out what
they're going to do with it so that's
probably something that we'll find out
about in next week's episode but number
two super herd serves the sanctuary it
was spectacular I feel like the way they
shot it it wasn't quite as big as I
expected they accomplished most of it
with CG like there were a couple low
shots of the walkers roaming by it
wasn't quite as big as they did back
during season five and then of course
number one was that final flash-forward
to old Rick in the hospital bed he gets
up you see an older version of baby
Judith and he goes outside into the safe
zone and then he flashes back to the
field where he's giving his speech and
says my mercy prevails over my wrath so
what that line means is is actually
directly out of the Quran I think and
it's supposed to be something like
reward for kindness and compassion is
assured by the Prophet Muhammad like the
whole idea is that Rick's not a
psychopath so his mercy will win out
mercy is the way even though they're
killing all kinds of people in this
episode but it was a great call to
action right at the end no matter what's
happened we've won they actually put
that in the season 8 trailer back at
Comic Con that was one of the big lines
of the season the only other real stray
observations you may have remembered is
that they sort of jumped back to a
moment from the pilot episode where Rick
first wakes up in that bed the room that
he wakes up in as old Rick looks exactly
like that so it's sort of their way of
celebrating how far they've come since
that pilot episode it's the hundredth
episode so I expected a couple special
things but the way they have this soft
camera filter on it makes it feel like a
dream sequence and this is something
that Rick is imagining formed the future
it's not an actual moment from the
future it's just something that he hopes
will eventually happen I'm not a hundred
percent on it either but Queens another
one bites the dust was the song that was
playing but let me know in the comments
what did you guys think of the episode
what was your favorite moment I think
that Rick was probably the MVP just
because of all the speeches he gave the
action was great but I feel like the
speeches were more important especially
in sort of teeing up what's going to be
happening the
season but I almost forgot he also said
that Maggie
should be running things after this is
all over implying that he wants her to
take over leadership of the safe zone
and hilltop but what'll happen is I'll
do a trailer video for episode 2 that'll
post on Monday while you wait for
everything you can click here for brand
new Game of Thrones and you can click
here from my non-spoilery thor ragnarok
review thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome i'll see you guys
tonight